you
I'm sure there's a lot of materials out
there smart materials materials that at
the nano level are being developed in
fact these come to the to the discipline
quite late so I'm probably not the right
person to ask that question but one of
the reasons that I went to MIT was in as
a way of being able to collaborate with
material scientists and begin to imagine
ways in which some of their work and our
work can become relevant to each other
but at another level I think it has not
to do so much with a material that's
going to revolutionize all of the
industry there are there are going to be
that and certainly the role of
composites has had a vast impact on the
way that we think about skins structural
skins the strength of skins and the way
that the boat building enterprise
airplane building has had an impact on
the way that we've in fact built
materials and furniture and skins in our
own firm has had the kind of
consequences that you're asking but I
think of them as very small steps
actually and and i think that there's a
there's a huge leap forward that we
still await
that was possible let's say until
several decades ago where education and
the advent of specialization had not
been so in a way stratified to the
degree that now knowledge has been put
on a rocket booster if you like the idea
that different disciplines are occupying
their own very distinct set of research
principles that are unaccessible to a
larger public it is busy it is becoming
more and more difficult to create great
generalists so part of our challenge I
think right now is how not to lose sight
of those very disciplinary traits that
characterize the core of your field on
the one hand while remaining agile and
able to engage the other disciplines in
such a way that you can give
architectural substance to their
knowledge the problem with these other
discipline groups is that they're
brilliant in what they do but they don't
necessarily understand their
architectural potential nor do they
understand their ability to synthesize
and only the architect is trained to
think in a way to take incompatible
elements and put them together into some
kind of synthesis whether it's a
difficult synthesis or a happy one is a
different question but the idea that the
architect is at a thinker and a great
improviser somebody who is able to pick
up the pieces and that's sort of what I
see is the next big challenge